this is amazing I don't know anybody has
ever done this what are you talking
about talking about this [ __ ] story
I heard I woke up Monday morning last
week and I was sitting here when the
show started and I started to get like
these cramps in my stomach
and I felt like okay I'll wait for the
next you know when the break comes I'll
run in do what I have to do and then
come back on the air you know you know I
go inside and I'm trying to [ __ ] and I
break out into the sweat room and I'm I
thought I was gonna pass out on the
toilet but quickly I got off and I came
back here and I couldn't sit down and
then you brought me back you brought me
into the show like towards the end of
the show and I would I was literally I
had to sit down to do it so you know you
could see the camera and everything I
was dying I was really dying
I was I was sweating my clothes was
soaked I felt like had a [ __ ] like it
was right I was ready to explode but
nothing would happen hmm
so as soon as the show ended I ran into
the bathroom I threw all my clothes off
and I'm sitting in i'm dude i was dying
somebody said you were screaming trying
to [ __ ] like you try and [ __ ] but
screaming yeah i was actually I was
actually crying at one point that's how
bad the pain Wow
when when mice one of my son's was young
the doctor used to tell used to tell us
you know if you know you got to help him
out sometimes so he's not in pain you
got to go in and get it what did you do
so I'm trying to remember what we did
and you should be like put vaseline on
your hand or like lube or something you
didn't have a glove oh [ __ ] man I had no
time for that I was in so much pain I'd
ran into I read I didn't even look for
Vaseline or anything I ran into the
bedroom and I knew we had this this Lube
that means Stephanie you know usually
were [ __ ] around it's did and I ran
in there and I got the bottle and I
ain't totally [ __ ] in my whole hand
in the loop okay toward it all over and
I'm sitting in I'm going what the [ __ ]
am I gonna do here and next thing I know
it's like
I had to I stuck my hand in there we
beat your hand my whole hand dude i
spring lays open as white as I could and
I stuck my I stuck my hand in there wait
a sec hold on a second hold on wait you
got to stop are you sitting down when
you're doing this like on the bowl well
both like we you know you have your
little rug by your shower and [ __ ] I
took that and threw the [ __ ] added room
right so if anything hit the floor I'd
be able to clean it up with no problem
smart um so I standing there one leg up
on the toilet seat and like spread my
ass open right and now my hand is all
covered in this dis goo when you say you
got your hand up there how many fingers
I mean you can't just put your hand up
there what are you he's drawing a finger
right all right no I I it was probably
three like these these three fingers
right Wow I just shoved it in there and
I'm pulling it was like it was like
[ __ ] cement Wow it's like cement huh
dude it was it was horrible so now I got
the first load out this first hand fault
how much comes out it was coming out in
pieces because it was I'm telling you it
was like pieces just like rocks cement
so now I'm taking and I'm throwing it in
the toilet okay and it's all over my
hands my hands call me go right back in
so now I sat down on the toilets
bergeron I'll be able to [ __ ] the rest
out now so what happened when I sat down
now it moved down into the same spot but
again it still wouldn't come out so now
I'm back up I'm standing it up again
doing the same thing pulling it out and
then it would ease up and then I'm
sitting down again figuring it'll come
out three times I had to pull it out and
then the last time that I sat down I'm
sitting there and I'm like pushing like
unbelievable I'm [ __ ] turning green I
could feel you know like I'm gonna
almost like gonna pass out and then all
of a sudden this big giant [ __ ] one
big brick came out and it was like I
gave birth Wow it all just [ __ ] eased
up and
and I was fine except the only problem
was I'm [ __ ] coveting [ __ ] right
what do you mean your hand yeah my hand
is a comedy [ __ ] so now I jump into the
[ __ ] shower got cleaned up and and
what's going on now have you [ __ ] since
then oh yeah yeah now I'm fine
Ronny puppet did you have a problem
[ __ ] I did have a problem as a
matter of fact I went in my [ __ ] so
tape
I lost my Timex in my colon I can't
believe he got his own hand up his
[ __ ] Oh a bare hand and he did it
three times I feel it wasn't the whole
hand it was like three fingers I was
using it like a claw like this you know
yes I would go to the I was sticking it
in like that and pulling out in anything
I could grant because it was right there
brick god that's that's what it looked
like I'm not kidding you why does he
ever rock in his [ __ ] house